Florentin will und der Tietzler, Podcast UFO, UFO, Podcast UFO. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO mit, wie schon angesprochen, Stefan Maria Tietzel und Florentin David Ridiculus. Ja, herzlich willkommen und heute mal wieder mit einem Beweis, einem erneuten Beweis, dass die menschliche Stimme doch das schönste Instrument ist. Vielen Dank, Max.
Wirklich Max?
Ja, Max ist, wie gesagt, Running Gag und oder eine extreme statistische Anomalie, dass einfach jeder Max heisst oder es ist ein kleiner Witz, den sich die Community hier macht. Es klang ein bisschen so, als ob du nicht so laut sein darfst.
Es klang ein bisschen so, als ob du in deinem Schlafzimmer im Kinderzimmer sitzt und nachts die Idee hattest, ein Podcast-Ufo-Intro aufzunehmen. Und die Eltern haben schon dreimal gesagt, du musst jetzt leise sein. Wir sind ein Gäste-Liste-Geisterbahn-Haushalt, du hörst diesen Schmutz hier nicht. Aber er, Max unter seiner Bettdeck, hat gesagt, nein, ich will ein Intro vermeiden. Podcast-Ufo, Podcast-Ufo. Aber aber es hat eine intimität erzeugt die ich ganz berauschend fand der vater kommt rein was habe ich da gerade gehört und er hat die decke als clever weil er hat sich versteckt er hat auf dem bett hat er nur mit kissen seine silhouette nachgebaut er hat schon unter das bett gekuselt. Er ist unter das Bett? Und dann kommt der Vater mit einem Schwert. Sticht in die Kissen rein. Na, wegen, es ist Nachtruhe, habe ich gesagt, Marx und haut mit einem Schwert. Ach, er heisst aber echt Marx? Ja, ja. Ach so, ja gut, das ist ja gut. Hä? War das zumindest keine Lüge, dann ist er, hä, hä?
Er heisst Marx.
Marx.
Ja, herzlich willkommen, schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid bei dem Podcast UFO.
Wir heißen euch ganz herzlich willkommen. Ey, vor allem, dass es geklappt hat, dass ihr es einrichten konntet.
Genau zur gleichen Zeit, wo wir es einrichten konnten, ist doch irgendwie cool, dass es immer so klappt.
Total, wir hatten Angst, niemand hat Zeit und niemand kommt vorbei, aber tatsächlich, ihr seid alle da.
Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid und
ihr könnt Fragen stellen, ihr könnt euch
melden, ihr könnt reinrufen,
wie ihr möchtet. Reinrufen
ist explizit erwünscht.
Ja, Stören ist Teil der
Show. Stört, stört gerne. Bitte, stört
jederzeit, stört,
werft Dinge,
trampelt mit den Füssen. Wir sind froh, wenn überhaupt
etwas passiert.
Genau, die letzten 387 Folgen kamen von euch. Nichts während der Aufnahme. Das überhaupt, aber ich finde es wirklich spannend, weil ich habe das Gefühl, alle können immer nicht. Alle haben keine Zeit, alle haben Vollterminkalender, alle müssen arbeiten. Dass ein Film entsteht. Unfassbar, ne? Dass alle zur gleichen Zeit im Google-Doodle die gleichen Tage freigelassen haben oder angekreuzt haben. Ich weiß nicht, wie es funktioniert. Dass George Clooney und Brad Pitt beide am selben Tag Zeit hatten, um Ocean's Eleven zu drehen. Irre! Dass er sagt so, ich hab, ne, Dienstag hab ich frei. Ja, wirklich? Matt Damon auch. Dienstag auch frei. Ja. Und alle kommen zusammen. Ja. Und Julia Roberts so, ah nee, aber da muss ich auch mal nicht da aufpassen. Okay, gut, da müssen wir noch alle nach einem Termin suchen. Bei Julia Roberts. Ja. Julia Roberts. Oh, die Oscar-Preisträgerin Julia Roberts. Julia Roberts. Aber mach mal so, pass auf, Leute, pass auf, meine Nichte kommt so gegen 13 Uhr von der Schule. Wenn wir... Sorry, da muss ich, George Clooney, hab ich da kurz einen Arzttermin. Okay, du, George Clooney, hast einen Arzttermin. Die Filler wieder ein. Die Filler nachmachen lassen. Ach Quatsch. Hier. Ach Quatsch. Für die emotionalen Szenen meinst du? Genau, damit sie nach hinten geht. Habe ich tatsächlich letztens so ein TikTok-Video gesehen, von Leuten, die sich das wirklich so mit so Tesafilmen nach hinten ziehen. Ich weiss nicht, ob das ein Gag ist oder nicht, aber es sah fantastisch aus. Sah es fantastisch aus? Es ist wirklich ganz grossartig. Ja, auch hier muss ich merken, dass ich da ein bisschen nicht mitbekommen habe, dass da die Zeit schon weiter ist. Da ist man irgendwie weiter. Ich bin in Diskussionen oder diesem Thema, glaube ich, so hinterher, wie so eine Szene von so einem Coming-of-Age-Film, wo ich dem Schulbus hinterherlaufe. Und alle lachen dich aus und winken hinten raus. Das Schönheits-OP steht über dem Bus, hinter dem ich hinterherlaufe als einsamer Schüler hinten dran. Stefan. Du bist bei allen Themen up to date, nur bei der Thematik Schönheits-OPs bist du noch nicht ganz dabei. Da bin ich dieses Meme. Okay. Was es auch nicht gibt. Aber es gibt diese Szene, gibt es ja häufig in so vielen Weltkriegen. Du hast ein neues Meme erschaffen. Ja, ein Gass. Das ist doch nicht schlecht. Ein Gass. Ja, okay, nebenbei. Oh, Internetgeschichte geschrieben. Oh mein Gott, kein Problem. Das passiert mir so nebenbei. Star Wars Kid, Stefan Tietze, das sind die grossen Ikonen der Internetgeschichte. Auch immer schlimm, wenn man dann googelt, was aus dem geworden ist. Ja. What happened to the, ähm, ich will nur Unreal Tournament spielen, Kid. Furchtbar, was denen passiert ist. Ganz interessant. Wenn ich mal eine Doku machen würde, wahrscheinlich mache ich eine, aber wenn ich eine machen würde, dann würde ich es über dieses Ich will Arnold Tournament spielen Kind machen, weil so wie ich die Geschichte in Erinnerung habe, gab es eine andere Person, die behauptet hat, sie war diese Person. Dann irgendwie, die hat man ja dann 20 Jahre lang nicht gesehen und irgendwann hat jemand einen YouTube-Kanal gemacht und hat gesagt, ich bin der echte Gangster, ich bin der Typ und hat dann so seinen Content gemacht und irgendwann kam jemand anders und meinte, nee, das stimmt nicht, ich bin der echte Unreal Tournament Kind. Und dann kam ein Dritter und hat gesagt, nee, ich bin das. Dann kam der Schreibtisch und meinte, ich bin der echte Schreibtisch, an dem der saß. Und dann haben die beiden gesagt, nee, dann waren die beiden das, und dann ist man zu denen hin und hat er gesagt, nee, einer von uns sagt die Wahrheit.
Genau. bin der echte Schreibtisch, an dem der saß. Und dann haben die beiden gesagt, nee, dann waren die beiden das, und dann ist man zu denen hin,
hat er gesagt, nee,
einer von uns sagt die Wahrheit, genau, und der andere
lügt immer, ja, so genau,
ich sag die Wahrheit, und der andere sagt,
nee, wie finden wir jetzt raus, wer von uns
immer lügt und wer immer die Wahrheit sagt,
oder dass beide lügen, super
schwierig, aber das wird natürlich in meiner Doku.
Nee, ganz einfach.
Man muss den einen fragen, was würde der andere ... Okay, alles klar. Ja, da können wir zum Glück im Schnitt noch mal viel machen. Aber das finde ich eine interessante Geschichte. Was würde der andere sagen, glaube ich. Das finde ich eine interessante Geschichte, was aus dem passiert ist. Und dass man natürlich sagt, in unserer knallharten Influencer-Gesellschaft, wo du wirklich dir jeden Like erarbeiten musst, einfach zu sagen, hey, noch niemand hat Besitz ergriffen an Ich bin das Froop-Mädchen, Frucht-Alarm-Mädchen, jeder kennt dieses Mädchen, aber niemand hat sich bekannt, es gab kein Bekennerschreiben jemals zu diesem Mädchen, also sagt man, ich bin die junge Influencerin, ich baue da einfach drauf auf. Ich sag, ich war damals das Frucht-Alarm-Mädchen und fange jetzt gleich mit 10.000 Followern an. Ich will die Stimme von den Cineminis. Cineminis! Du warst die Stimme von Cineminis, ja. Wow, ich folge dir. Ah cool, kriege ich jetzt, wie viel Geld kriege ich jetzt? Naja, du hast jetzt Möglichkeiten, Product Placements
zu machen mit verschiedenen Konflikten. Ich habe 200
Follower jetzt bekommen, glaube ich. Ja,
wenn 200 Leute unser Produkt
kaufen würden, wären wir schon froh.
Sag ich dir gleich. Okay, das klingt so,
als ob sie es wirklich nötig haben und kein
gutes Produkt haben. Wir machen, also, unser Produkt
ist mittelmässig, wir machen so eine Art
Überraschungsei, aber halt nicht das Kinderüberraschungsei,
sondern halt so ein No-Name-Überraschungsei. Was man lange ausbrüten muss. Das muss man sich neun Monate lang draufsetzen. Und was ist dann drin? Irgendwie was Cooles oder so? Also bei uns war das Problem, wir haben halt die Schokolade innen reingemacht und die Überraschung ist außen. Also die Überraschung ist die Schale und die Schokolade ist innen. Es gibt jetzt wenig Überraschungen, die gut in so eine Hülle ... Das ist keine Überraschung, man weiss, dass es ein Schokoei ist. Genau, das dachten wir nämlich auch. Das Innere ist nicht eine Überraschung, das Äussere ist eine Überraschung. Also du packst das Ei aus und sagst dann, wow, eine Hülle, es ist die blaue Hülle oder die gepunktete Hülle. Und was dann im Ei drin ist, das ist keine Überraschung mehr. Und leider muss man es neun Monate lang ausbrüten und dann ist die Schokolade oft schon geschmolzen, mehrmals geschmolzen, wieder hart geworden, geschmolzen, hart geworden, hart geworden. Okay, dann muss ich aber on camera sagen, ha, ich bin die Stimme von Cindy Minis, so ist mir der Gang und übrigens kauf doch die Überraschungseier. Ja, das Ö-Ei. Das Ö-Ei. Das ist das Ö-Ei. Okay, und dann muss ich sagen, dass es gut ist oder Selbsterfahrung? Ja, das wäre gut. Sag bitte es authentisch, dass du es selber gerne nutzt und dass du es gut benutze. Dass ich es jeden Tag nutze und ich sage, dass ich ein besseres Leben habe. Genau. Und bitte. Hi, ich bin die Stimme von Cidimimis, vielleicht kennt ihr mich. Cidimimis, Cidimimis. Und hier ist das Ö-Ei. Perfekt, wunderbar, das ist so gut. Also das hat uns sehr gut gefallen. Das nehmen wir so, danke schön. Das ist eine furchte Werbung, die wir jemals bekommen haben. Wir haben leider wenig Budget, also gerade im Social-Media-Zeitalter kauft man ja dann so 10.000, in 10.000 Feeds taucht es auf. Wir haben leider nur genug Geld für einen einzigen
Feed. Also diese Werbung wird einer
einzigen Person angezeigt
werden. Nur eine einzige Person
sieht diese Werbung. Die so gelangweilt im Zug
ist und dann so weg. Und genau als diese Werbung
kommt dann so ein
Entschuldigung? Ach so, das ist
Hermannplatz. Genau, Hermannplatz.
Und dann war, das war's. Das war
der Moment.
Aber ist das eine gute Idee für ein Gewinnspiel? Eine einzige Person kriegt die geheime Werbung, die goldene Werbung mit einem Code und gewinnt dann was. Das ist eine richtig gute Idee. Das wird nur ein einziges Mal ausgespielt. Impression eins. Und dann geht's raus. Und dann kriegt nur eine Person das und dann sagt sie, du hast gewonnen. Aber man wird's wegscrollen. Man wird's einfach wegscrollen. Man wird's einfach wegscrollen. Man hat so Angst vor diesen du hast gewonnen Mails und so, dass man schon genau, man kann sich heutzutage kaum noch über einen Gewinn freuen. Du bist verloren, wer hingegen die Mail dich sofort anklicken würde. Du hast nicht gewonnen. Och, geil, was habe ich nicht gewonnen? Krass, ich klicke gerne auf den Link. Ja, ich meine, das wäre zum Beispiel, finde ich, eine sehr zeitkritische Werbung. Also sagen wir mal, jemand kommt nach Hause von einem harten Arbeitstag, Kragen ist offen, Krawatte hängt schief, kommt nach Hause. Blutfleck. Blutfleck, man hört schon die Kinder schreien im Haus, macht macht den ähm Der Familienhund liegt draußen tot auf der Mauer. Überfahren, der Kopf wurde zermatscht. Typischer Kackarbeitstag. Genau, er macht den Briefkasten auf, nimmt so einen ganzen Packen Briefe raus. Und den Pferdekopf. Der Pferdekopf, der tote Igel und man sieht so Mahnung, letzte Rechnung. Letzte Warnung. Letzte Rechnung. Und dann macht er die Tür auf, die Frau ist überfordert, irgendwie, man gibt sich einen lieblosen Kuss, schaut sich kaum an, setzt sich in den Sessel, geht diese Briefe durch. Die Frau hat so eine Nerf Gun-Patrone, so in den Haaren und eine im Ohr. Ja, genau. Und dann geht er diese Briefe durch, Mahnung, Mahnung, Rechnung, und eines der Briefe ist das goldene Ticket von Willy Wonka, aber dadurch, dass er so gestresst ist, legt er die einfach alle in den Müll. Er sieht gar nicht, was er für ein Geschenk bekommen hat. Headspace, um endlich wieder achtsam die Momente wahrnehmen zu können, dessen Glück euch verborgen bleibt in einem stressigen Alltag.
Headspace, dess dessen Glück euch verborgen bleibt in einem stressigen Alltag. Headspace.
Dessen Glück. Wir haben extra noch mal einen Grammatiker eingeladen. Wir haben extra den teuersten Autoren Hollywoods genommen. Aber irgendwie ist es doch nicht so kampflich. Headspace. Für die Momente, deren Glücksgriffe ihr erst merkt, wenn ihr zuweilen nach Hause kommt, im Arbeitsstress verschluckt seiend, nach Juweluft japsend nach Hause kommend, der Frau mit Nerfgun, das haben wir alles gesehen. Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Da muss ich auch sagen, also ich tue mich auch manchmal schwer mit der deutschen Sprache, we finally did it, ich tue mich auch manchmal schwer mit der deutschen Sprache und muss immer noch mal kurz innehalten bei diesem mit einem kleinen Teil, ja, dieses M, N, mit einem kleinen Glied und so, ähm, aber ich finde dieses Problem und immer wenn ich dieses Problem hat mit einem Hub, einem kurzen Penem, dann muss ich immer denken, wie ein einer der grössten Künstler der Musikgeschichte dieses Problem ganz elegant gelöst hat. Und zwar muss ich immer denken an Grupp-Täckern. Einem kleinen. Wo bist du mein Sonnenlicht? Mit der, glaube ich, perfekten Liedzeile Ich vermisse deinem Atem. Danach war alles möglich. Und da ist einfach die deutsche Sprache durchgespielt, weil das ist ja völlig klar, ich vermisse deinem Atem. Und das ist so perfekt auf den Punkt, deinem Atem. Und jedes Mal denke ich daran, wie war das nochmal, mit deinem, deinem, penem. Aber ich vermisse deinen Atem, ist auch ein bisschen eine creepy line. Ja, ein bisschen schon, ja. Seitdem du so reglos vor mir liegst, vermisse ich deinen Atem. Also irgendwie, es hat so eine Art mit der Person noch, es ist ein bisschen eine merkwürdige Zeile. Ja, Romantik ist sehr schwer, weil du kannst ... Dirty Talk, auch sehr schwer. Ja, es gibt ganz spezielle Körperteile, die man herausstellen kann, andere nicht. Zum Beispiel die Augen. Man kann eigentlich alles über die Augen sagen, wunderschöne Augen, strahlende Augen. Niemand sagt, also wie sagt es jetzt über meine Augen, so Augen sind einfach frei. Alle anderen Körperteile sind schon tricky. Ich liebe deine Achseln. Wie bitte? Ich liebe deine Achseln. Meine Achseln? Ja. Wie meinst du, warum fallen dir die auf? Sind wunderschön Wachseln. Hä, warum fallen dir die meine Achseln auf? Achseln sind Fenster zur Seele. So, ich glaube... Ich liebe deine Achseln, die sind so wunderschön gebaut. Du bist wunderschön. Zeig mir, zeig mir, wenn ich in deine Achseln gucke, weiß ich, ich bin zu Hause. Ja, es ist wirklich schwierig. Ich sehe mich in deinen Achseln. Okay. Danke, ich finde es ja auch toll, also ja, aber es ist, weiß ich nicht, ich weiß nicht, wie ich mich fühlen soll. Deine Stirn, deine Stirnfalten, um genau zu sein, sind genau immer wenn ich da reinschaue, in die Stirnfalten, denke ich mir, wo warst du die letzten Jahre? Wo waren wir? Was habe ich verpasst? Ich will, ich will mir, ich will dir, ich will dir mein Gesicht in deine Stirnfalten drücken und ich will, will, will mit dir die Zeit aufholen, die wir für dich verpasst haben. Schatz, ich liebe dich. Schatz, ich will und ich vermisse deinen Atem. Ich vermisse auch deine Atem. Es ist wirklich schwierig. Ja, du hast völlig recht. Man kann manche Sachen nicht so gut herausstellen wie andere Sachen. Eigentlich nur die Augen. Na gut, Augen, gut. Das ist ja interessant, aber die Augen, finde ich, sind ja ... Also habt ihr schon jemals wirklich schöne Augen gehabt? Ist es wirklich oder ist es nur so, was man sagt? Doch, ich finde, man kennt sie. Ich kenne Menschen mit sehr schönen Augen. Aber was heißt das? Weil die sind ja immer Kugeln. Wir haben zwei kleine. Wir haben jeweils zwei kleine. Wir haben winzig kleine Maulwurf-Eugler. Wenn ich lache, sind die weg. Sind die weg? Aber vor allem, ich finde, es ist so konterintuitiv, weil Augen sind ja Kugeln. Das ist ja die mathematisch präziseste Form für einen Körperteil. Da ist ja die wenigste Individualität in den Augäpfeln, weil die sind immer eine Kugel. Mund, Nase, Ohren, alle anderen Körperteile sind. Das ist die Augenform natürlich spannend, wie gross sind die, wie gross wirken sie. Aber die sind immer gleich, die ist immer eine Kugel. Ich glaube sogar, dass Augen immer gleich gross sind, da habe ich mal irgendwo gehört. Also Augen, es gibt so gut wie keine Grössenverschieden zwischen grossen, kleinen Menschen. Also die haben immer gleich grosse Augen. Und ich glaube, die wachsen auch nicht so. Ist das nicht so, auch dass die nicht wachsen im Laufe der Zeit? Genau, aber es ist so, du hast recht, es ist eine sehr präzise Form. Ja. Es ist immer gleich gross, also eigentlich gibt es nicht so viel herauszustellen. Es gibt ja die Augenfarbe, okay, aber da gibt es vier verschiedene. Gut, okay. Danke, abgehakt, vielen Dank, ciao.
Gut, fertig, dann, ja, du hast grüne Augen, Punkt.
Vielen Dank, Romantik, abgehakt, Rommel, Rommel, Pragmatik, Vorpflanzung.
Bei anderen Körperteilen, finde ich, hast du viel mehr Individualität, aber irgendwie geht es immer um die Augen, ich weiß nicht.
Vielleicht bin ich da auch einfach nur neidisch.
Du hast wunderschönen Lippen.
Danke, vielleicht bin ich da auch einfach nur neidisch, weil ich natürlich meine kleinen winzigen Maulwurstäuglein habe, die oft vergessen werden, wenn ich gezeichnet werde, sind einfach Punkte, so wie Milhouse, der einfach ohne Brille einfach nur einzelne Punkte hat.
Aber so habe ich mich gefühlt, als ich dann meine Brille nicht mehr getragen habe, was auch daran lag, so mit Covid und so und Masken auf und super nervig immer beschlagen. Und dann, man kennt sich ja dann mit Brillen. Ja. Und als ich die weg hatte, habe ich mich so gefühlt auf jedem Bild und immer im Spiegel guckend immer wie Milhouse ohne Brille, weil irgendwie, keine Ahnung, man hat dann so, es wird auch ein bisschen ja verzer, das Bild, was man sieht, durch die Brille, durch dieses Glas, und dann wirken die Augen so ein bisschen rausgestellter. Wenn man die Brille dann, kennt ihr ja, wenn die Leute nur die Brille kennen und die verlieren die Brille, sieht es immer merkwürdig aus. Es sieht aus wie zwei Punkte, das habe ich sehr gut getroffen, von den wie so oft treffsicheren Simpsons. Aber es ist toll, dass wir auch die Augen verbessern können.
Zum Beispiel ich persönlich, ich rieche nicht gut.
Also ich habe, ich bemerke immer wieder, dass wenn andere Leute sagen, hier riecht es nicht gut oder das riecht gut, ich kriege es nicht mit. Ich habe einfach eine schlechte Nase, ich kriege es nicht mit.
Es gibt für mich keine Nasenbrille.
Es gibt für mich keinen Noptiker, zu dem ich hingehen kann und sage, Hörn Sie, kann ich mal einen Riechtest machen? Was sind meine Riechtest? Selbstverständlich, lassen Sie sich gerne mal dahin, lassen Sie sich gerne mal dahin. So, und jetzt hier hinten, so jetzt konzentrieren Sie sich mit der Nase einfach kurz auf diesen Schaukasten hier hinten. Okay. Und ich würde jetzt nacheinander diese Fächer aufmachen, die Aromen erfüllen den Raum und wir fangen mit sehr, sehr lauten, klaren Aromen an und werden dann ein bisschen subtiler, okay? Alles klar. Ich mache jetzt das erste auf. Oh mein Gott! Ich kriege noch nichts. Was? Ich kriege noch nichts. Was, wieso denn nichts? Der ganze Raum stinkt. Ah, okay, ähm, ich krieg so einen Hauch Benzin. Benzin? Ja, Jesus Christ. Okay, wir werden ein bisschen subtiler. Sie scheinen ihren Job nicht so sehr zu mögen. Es ist so unangenehm, es ist so unangenehm. Tut mir leid, es geht auch aus der Kabine nicht mehr raus, diese Gewürze. Ach so, okay, das ist natürlich blöd. So, zweite. Ich krieg gar nichts, ich krieg überhaupt nichts. Sie riecht ihrer gar nichts. Ich krieg überhaupt nichts. Sie riechen gar nichts. Hier und jetzt hier? Kommt nichts an. Ah, das ist ein bisschen faule Eier, ist das faule Eier? Nein, Gas. Ach so. Okay, also, ja, ich komm nicht drumrum in ... Wie viele Schniefoptrien habe ich denn? Minus neun. Minus neun, okay, das ist härter als ich dachte und können wir dann gleich ein modell aussuchen die nasen noch zu halten jetzt besser schlechter und die andere zu halten jetzt besser oder schlechter viel schlechter ja okay auf den aden macht Sinn das ist immer schlechter okay dann bekommen sie jetzt diese Nasenbrille. Okay, oh, die ist schön. Genau, also die, ne, ich setze die kurz ein.
Ja. Und da hat man hier so ein Ding. Ja, die hat also, die hat eigentlich einen schönen Rahmen. Die hat einen schönen Rahmen. Gibt es die auch in einer anderen Stärke oder... Oh, ich rieche, ich merke, ich rieche das besser gerade. Sehen Sie schon? Ich rieche das besser gerade. Am Anfang kannst du halt ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen auslösen oder so, müsste sich daran gewöhnen. Es wird ein bisschen schrubrig gerade. Ich merke, es wird gerade ein bisschen schrubrig. Okay, dann machen wir die kurz raus. Wir machen die kurz raus. Okay, alles klar. Nee, das war schon ganz gut. Dieses Gestell ist ein bisschen teurer. Ach so, ja. Das ist ein Designergestell. Aber das hat mir gut gefallen. Das steht der Nase gut, finde ich. Wollen wir mal was ausprobieren oder wollen wir uns dafür schon entscheiden? Vielleicht, wenn Sie noch ein preiswerteres haben. Ich würde mal, das ist nach unserer Hausmarke hier. Ah ja. Einmal das aufsetzen, das Nasenbettel. Ja, das sieht eigentlich auch ganz rot aus. Das ist eigentlich ganz nett. Und da, ah ja, ich merke, als der Tricks besser ist nichts. Wenn ich jetzt mal hier unten das Törchen aufmache, was riechen Sie jetzt? Ja, das ist Kot, ja. Das ist Kot, das rieche ich direkt. Genau, und jetzt hier nochmal, und jetzt ganz letzte Reihe unten. Oh, letzte Reihe, das ist Verwesung, ist das Verwesung? Das ist Verwesung, ja. Super. Oh, das habe ich gut gehochen, dann nehme ich die, dann würde ich die günstigere nehmen. Herein? Das ist nicht mein Laden. Wir applaudieren immer.
Entschuldigung, meine Ohren sind auch irgendwie ein bisschen schwach. Ah ja, okay. Im Nebenraum. Aber man hat keine Chance. Also Leute, die nicht gut sehen können, da hat die Gesellschaft sofort ein Netz parat. Also für meinen Bootsführerschein musste ich damals ja einen Hörtest machen. Zum ersten Mal haben wir eben einen Hörtest gemacht. Und dann war ich beim Optiker, kontraintuitive Weise, musste man sich da hinsetzen.
Sie sind hier falsch. Ah, da gehe ich wieder. Und dann geht man in so eine Kabine und dann kriegt man so einen Kopfhörer auf, ne, beziehungsweise einmal einen Kopfhörer auf, da muss man drücken, sobald man das Geräusch hört. Und dann gibt es einen zweiten Test, da muss man sich hinsetzen und der Abstand ist genormt zu den Boxen, die oben in den Ecken sind.
Aha.
Und die Boxen sagen dann Wörter, da ist ein Sprecher, der sagt dann Wörter wie Baum, Raum, Zaun, man muss das Wort wiederholen. Schwer, die sind ähnlich dann. Und das ist ein bisschen albern, weil dann sitzt du da mit jemandem im Raum und es kommt voller Lautstärke, da sagt jemand Baum und du sagst, ja Baum. Also und das ist halt das Album, weil es ist nicht so, es ist irgendwie gelernt, wenn da ein großes A steht, zu sagen A, C, F, G, aber wenn dann voller Lautstärke sagt, einfach nur ein Sprecher Baum und man sagt dann Baum. Ja, aber kommt sich dumm vor, wir wissen nicht, wo man ansetzt. Schrecklich. Eigentlich sollte der Typ, der das macht, okay, wir konnten uns unterhalten bis jetzt, wir können eigentlich hier bei Level 3 einsteigen. Ja, genau, exakt. Und dann jemand, mit dem ich den Butcher schon gemacht habe, ist dann aber zu einem ganz normalen Hausarzt gegangen, was auch geht, da kann man nämlich auch einen Hörtest machen. Na, der Hausärzte kann alles, oder? Aber was der gemacht hat, der hätte nämlich dann nicht den genormten Abstand zu den Boxen und dem Sitz oder er hatte auch nicht dieses Tape, was man abspielt, sondern er hatte eine Liste mit Wörtern, hat sich in die Ecke gestellt und hat sich mit diesem Zettel in die Ecke gestellt, an die Wand guckend und gesagt, Baum, Zaun. Und er musste ... Und er wurde immer leiser? Ja, er wurde leiser. Und es wirkte so gefühlig, so unwissenschaftlich. Und dann, mit dem ich das gemacht habe, musste er dann halt immer sagen, was er gehört hat. Das ist super unangenehm. Ja, aber es ist ja gar nicht so leicht. Also versucht mal zehn Wörter zu lesen und wirklich sukzessive leiser zu werden, immer mit dem gleichen Abstand. Das ist ja ... Ja, vor allem ... Also das ist ja ist ja da muss ja Profimusiker sein. Und jeder kennt das, wenn man einen Song anfängt zu singen.
Man merkt, okay, es wird viel zu hoch.
Und genau so stellt man vor, er fängt viel zu leise an.
Er hat dann keinen Raum mehr.
Warum ist schon erst bei Wort fünf von, schon bei der Lautstärke, sagen, sagen, sagen, sagen.
Ja, okay, viel Spaß mit allen fünf Wörtern.
Leichenschmauze, einfach, wenn man sagt, sieht's.
Ist wirklich schwer. Wer kann, gibt's denn ein Guinness-Buch der Rekorde für das leiseste Sprechen? Ähm, ähm. Also es gibt ja bestimmt für die lauteste, gibt's ja so Dezibelmesser, aber wirklich zu sagen, das, wie soll man das machen, das leiseste noch registrierbare Geräusch. Ja, aber dann, ne? Also ich würde gerne meinen Rekord einreichen. Das leiseste Geräusch. Das leiseste Geräusch, was man mit dem Mund machen kann. Ja, das ist. Aber Sie haben jetzt schon tausend Geräusche gemacht, die leiser sind. Ach so, ach so. Sie meinen, die die gar nicht gehört haben.
Ja, dann nehmen Sie das.
Das kann ich ja auch.
Ja gut, aber Sie arbeiten bei Guinness.
Ja, das ist ein Argument.
Gibt es nicht die Regel, dass Sie keine
Rekorde einreichen dürfen?
Wir müssen alles können.
Ach so. Nur wer alles kann, kann alles bewerten.
Verstehen Sie?
Nur wer alles kann, kann alles bewerten. Verstehen Sie? Nur wer alles kann, kann auch alles bewerten. Wir brauchen dich, Guinness. Ist das die Biermarke eigentlich? Nein, weil ich glaube, es ist natürlich ein Problem, wenn du bei Guinness arbeitest und es kommen Leute, die wollen Weltrekord machen. Ist die Barclays Premier League. Ist auch Ist auch eine andere Marke. Ich meine, Guinness, die Biermarke, also Red Bull ist ja nicht nur, man hat ja auch verschiedene Branchen, sozusagen. Soll ich dir den Arzt rufen? Ich verstehe, ich habe überhaupt keine Ahnung, wo du gerade bist. Die Biermarke Guinness kann ja dieses Rekordbuch sozusagen begründet haben. Ja, haben sie aber nicht. Okay, aber gut, dass wir das mal geklettert haben. Wenn du sagst, nein, es hat gar nichts damit zu tun, sie heissen einfach beide Guinness. Mir ist schon klar, dass sie beide gleich heissen, Stefan. Also da sind wir schon dabei. Okay, aber gut, hast du es vielleicht nicht selbstbewusst genug gesagt, weil ich dachte, okay. Nee, es kann gut durchaus sein, dass es das gleiche ist. Ja, aber es ist halt nicht so. Okay, aber gut. Hast du es gegoogelt? Vielleicht ist es auch so. Guinness Bierrekord. Ein bis heute ungebrochener Weltrekord. Der Engländer Peter Doudswell schaffte in drei Stunden 45 Liter Bier. 45 Liter Bier. Da! Es wurde von der Brauerei ein Auftrag gegeben, das Buch. Scheiße. Wie uncool ist das denn? Jetzt hab auch die Grösse zu sagen, dass du falsch lagst. Hab die Grösse. Also ich hab die Grösse hier auch zuzugeben. Vor allem hier steht... Also, fast allen ist der Begriff Genes Buch der Rekorde geläufig. Doch was ausgerechnet die Brauerei aus Irland damit zu tun hat, wissen nur die wenigsten. Beweismittel A. Ja, ich weiß es nicht. In diesem Beitrag soll es nicht darum, das finde ich gut, dass ein Artikel damit anfängt, worum es nicht geht. Erstmal alles aus dem Weg schaffen, worum es nicht geht. In diesem Beitrag soll es nicht darum drehen, dass Schorschbock 57 aus dem Frankenland mit 57% Alkoholgehalt das stärkste Bier ist, oder die kleinste Bierflasche der Welt, nur eine Größe von 15,96 Millimeter. Worum redest du? Worum geht es in diesem Ort? Auch wenn all diese Fakten als Weltrekord im Guinness-Buch stehen, sondern darum, warum der Begriff Guinness... Ja, 1955 wurde ein Buch von der Guinness-Brauerei in Antwort gegeben und anschließend auch in Irland veröffentlicht. Der Daming-Autoren waren die Zwillinge Ross und Norris McWhirter. Also, ich habe die grösse auch zuzugeben dass ich hier einen fehler gemacht habe aber ich will dir kurz erklären wo meine arrogante selbstsicherheit herkam ich habe nämlich als kind in irland ein guinness abfüllwerk besuch in irland habe ich ein guinness museum abfüllbetrieb dublin ja mein Mein Vater und Onkel sind große Guinness-Biertrinker, ich war ein Kind. Und wir sind da gemeinsam hingegangen. Lassen Sie das Kind mitnehmen zum Saufwochenende, war das ein bisschen die Idee? Na ja, da wurde der eine oder andere Hahn gezapft, aber jetzt auch nicht übermässig so. Und ich war damals ein großer Guinness-Buch der Rekorde-Fan und deswegen war in meinem Kopf, hätte es eine Verbindung gegeben, hätte
ich das hundertprozentig erfahren bei
dieser Guinness-Buchführung und bei dieser
Guinness-Bier-Führung
bei dieser
Hey, alles gut? Ich habe das Gefühl,
in solchen Momenten ist immer klar,
wie es einem gerade geht.
Es ist einfach wahnsinnig viel Druck auf mir,
Stefan, es tut mir leid.
Es ist einfach wahnsinnig viel Druck und da dachte Stefan, es tut mir leid. Es ist einfach wahnsinnig viel Druck. Und da dachte ich mir, wäre es so gewesen, wäre es so gewesen, wir sind seit Wochen in diesem Raum, Stefan.
Warum? Du kannst nach Hause. Wieso kommst du nicht mehr raus? Ich finde die Tür nicht mehr.
Geh auch mit mir gleich raus. Das ist kein Problem. Du gehst immer schon als erstes raus und dann sage ich komm mal zweitens. Ich finde die Tür nicht. Ich dachte, wenn wir das, wenn das einen Zusammenhang gäbe, hätten wir es da erfahren. Aber da ich es nicht erfahren habe, habe ich es auch nicht jedem. So oder so, ich hatte unrecht, Stefan hat recht, herzlichen Glückw ein Museum zu stellen und zu sagen, welche Stadt ist das. Geoguesser sollen sich alte Gemälde angucken, die irgendwie in der Realität fussen und sagen, ah, das ist ähm das ist Kapstadt, äh, welche Stadt auch immer, das ist Bremen, das ist ähm ja, irgendeine Stadt, einfach irgendeine europäische Stadt in Deutschland. Genau, das zum Beispiel. Irgendeine europäische Stadt, Stefan, irgendeine Stadt, irgendeine deutsche Stadt, einfach irgendeine. Der Mond. Nee, nee, auch schon auf der Erde, irgendeine irgendeine Stadt. Nein, nein, nein, einfach nur irgendeine deutsche Stadt, egal welche, wirklich. Um eine zu nennen. Eine mit M, eine mit O, eine mit D. Rhein. Nein, das ist ein Fluss. Achso, das ist ein Fluss. Ja, genau, dann setzt man sie da hin und dann soll sie sagen. Einfach irgendeinen Namen. Ja, irgendeinen Stadtmacht. Zum Beispiel mit U. Urne. Okay. Vielleicht solltest du das nicht moderieren. Vielleicht finden wir da wirklich noch jemand anderen, der das moderiert. Aber ich fand das so spannend, weil dann sehen die ja, das ist meins. Ah, okay, jetzt verstehe ich. Finde ich eine gute Idee. Ja, das kann man gut kombinieren, so Museen plus Geogäser.
Weil die sehen, also ich finde ja, wenn Geogasting eins gezeigt hat, dieser ganze Trend, ist das Menschen, da sind ja Menschen unglaublich gut darin. Unfassbar gut.
Wo man auch sagt, okay, wahrscheinlich können Menschen, ich finde das, weil die sind so stark darin, dass sie so Millisekunden, nicht nur Kontinent, sondern sogar Land sagen können, dass ich mir denke, ah, weil die sind, hast du das auch, wenn jemand so stark ist, weil bei Menschen, die schnell rennen, denke ich mir, ja gut, das ist schon sehr beeindruckend, da muss man sehr viel für trainieren, krass, aber der rennt halt so schnell, wenn man viel trainiert, kann man auch so. Aber das ist so far away, dass ich mir denke, ah, Menschen sind darin wahrscheinlich einfach gut. Ja, absolut. Ich wette das so ab. Vor allem, ich, manchmal diese Geogässer Weltmeister und so, die sind ja so krass, wo ich mir wirklich denke, kann man wirklich die gesamte Erde kennen? Genau. Also kann man wirklich so, wie man sich vielleicht in der Stadt orientieren kann oder in seinem Heimatdorf kennt man jede Ecke, kann man wirklich die vollständige Welt, also ist das möglich? Ich bewerte den Skill viel geringer jetzt, weil ich denke, ja, Menschen können das einfach gut. Menschen, wenn man ein kurzes Auge aufmacht, muss man wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung, irgendwie aufgrund wo wir herkommen als Menschheit,
irgendwie an die Andertaler-Shit, man muss dann irgendwann, man muss ja schnell gecheckt haben, wo man ist oder so.
Okay, also du sagst jetzt, wenn du sagst, wir machen jetzt die Weltmeisterschaft der Affen, wer klettert am schnellsten?
Sitzt du im Publikum gähnend, Erdnüsse, Mampfen und sagst, ja gut, Affen können halt schnell klettern.
Affen können halt krass schnell klettern. Also das ist jetzt keine Kunst, wohingegen, wenn Fische klettern würden. Und das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr der beste Kletterfisch, da sagst du so. Und der klettert sehr, sehr schlecht. Ja, aber für den Fisch, ja. Ich sehe keine wahnsinnige Leistung, darum geht es mir nicht. Ich finde nur, die Geogässer sind so gut alle, dass ich mir denke, wahrscheinlich sind Menschen einfach sehr, sehr gut, sich in der Umgebung zurechtzufinden. Das ist ein Problem, ja. Deswegen, ich finde natürlich, weil wir haben letztens über Olympiade auch nochmal überlegt, wie kann man Olympiade cooler machen? Ich finde natürlich so Crossover-Sportarten gut. Also zum Beispiel, du hast erst Sprinten, dann hast du Fahrradfahren. Und dann versucht der, der schnellste Sprinter tritt gegen den langsamsten Fahrradfahrer an. Und man guckt, kann der schnellste Sprinter schneller sein als der langsamste Fahrradfahrer. Also nochmal die in Relation setzen, die verschiedenen Sportarten, zu gucken, wie macht man das? So, also der schlechteste Speerwerfer gegen den besten Kugelstoßer. So, kommt der weiter mit seiner Kugel als der schlechteste Speerwerfer. Um auch herauszufinden, welche Leute sind einfach falsch in ihrem Job. Richtig. Weil wenn der beste Speerwerfer besser ist als der schlechteste Kugelstosser im kugelstossen ach so nee ich meine die die werfen schon ihren speer also der der sprinter rennt schon neben dem fahrradfahrer auf seinem fahrrad her aber du guckst halt wie die sportarten zueinander stehen okay um dann die beste sportart sozusagen ein turnier der sportarten um dann gucken, wie stehen die eigentlich im Verhältnis, weil du hörst, du siehst immer nur innerhalb ihrer Sportart, aber du weißt gar nicht, wie sind die im Verhältnis, weil das Leistungsniveau in unterschiedlichen Sportarten kann ja unterschiedlich hoch sein, also zum Beispiel die Speerwerfer sind extrem krass, super elitär, Hammerwerfer kann ich hiermachen. So, weil da gibt es halt drei Leute.
Da müsste man Speerwerfer Hammer werfen lassen.
Du willst den, der beste Speerwerfer wirft einen Hammer und der beste Hammerwerfer wirft einen Speer.
Wenn der beste Speerwerfer aus dem Stand besser einen Hammer wirft als der beste Hammerwerfer, würde ich sagen, die Sportart ist tot.
Weg.
Weg. Weg. Wir radieren die aus. Ja, ja. Das ist meine sagen, die Sportart ist tot. Weg!
Wir radieren die aus.
Das ist meine Zeit, die hier drauf geht.
Ja, du musst dir das angucken.
Ich muss mir diese Scheisse angucken.
Und ich wusste bislang nicht, dass es sehr schlecht ist.
Kann ja sein, dass es so eine Sportart gibt,
wo sich alle wahnsinnig ausruhen gerade.
Weil das sieht schon krass aus.
Dieser Hammer, den die werfen, gibt es
überhaupt noch? Diskuswerfen oder so?
Niemand hat mal eine Diskus-Scheibe,
ein Diskus.
Ja, das eine des... Weil das sieht schon krass aus. Dieser Hammer, den die werfen, gibt es das überhaupt noch? Diskuswerfen oder so? Niemand hat mal eine Diskusscheibe, ein Diskus. Man hat das letzte Mal ein Disc in der Hand, so einen richtigen Diskus. Nie. Du meinst das so eine Art Kartell, wo die sagen, ey, dieses Jahr machst du die, machst du 18 Meter, ich mache 17 Meter, nächstes Jahr kannst du die Goldmedäne.
Ja genau, wir trainieren nicht, es sind alles Profisportler, es ist doch schwer da reinzukommen, aber die trainieren nicht, die können sich, aber dann stehen Sperrwäffer daneben und sehen das und denken, ja anscheinend ist es schwer, aber der wird der Beste der Welt, Gregori Marschinov, schafft es nur irgendwie, keine Ahnung, fünf Meter und es ist das krasseste und alle anderen schaffen es auch nicht weiter, es ist vermutlich der Beste und der wird doch hart dafür trainieren. Dann Cut zu seinem Trainingslager, er sitzt mit dem fucking Pepsi Light vom Netflix. Ja, aber im Trainingslager. Die gehen schon jeden Tag zum Training, aber schauen Suits einfach nur die ganze Zeit. Die müssen ja schon noch irgendwie ihren Schein wagen. Genau, die brauchen auch so diese Anzüge und so, muss alles schon richtig sein. Ich hatte letztens tatsächlich mit einem Profifussballer zu tun für ein Event bei Rocket Beans und das ist ja eine Welt, mit der kenne ich mich gar nicht aus. Also weder erfolgreich, also weder Fußball noch Sport noch generell erfolgreiche Menschen, also objektiv erfolgreiche Menschen. Ich habe sonst nie, ich habe mit Leuten, die Ambitionen haben, da habe ich viel mit Leuten. Mit ehrgeizigen Wichtern. Ehrgeizigen Leuten, die denken, sie wären erfolgreich. Aber jemand, der wirklich sagt, ich bin Bundesliga-Spieler, ist eine grosse Leistung, wo man einfach sagt, okay, du bist einfach krass. Aber ich glaube, ich habe nicht wirklich eine Ebene mit dem gefunden. Weil ich dachte, okay, da komme ich jetzt so kumpelhaft und dachte, ich stelle ein paar Fragen und so. Aber ich weiß nicht. Hattest du Vorurteile gegenüber Leistungssportlern, also gerade Fussballern, dumm? Ja, ich dachte, die sind halt sehr also sehr spezialisiert. Die können extrem gut Fussball spielen, aber bei allem anderen sind die raus, aber nee, stimmt nicht, die sind einfach auch mental stark und krass und erkennen sofort, was muss hier passieren. In welcher Situation? Gerade wenn man so ein Mannschaftssport ist und so, muss man gucken, wie setzt man wen ein
und wie macht man das jetzt am besten, wie setzt man
seinen Joker am besten ein, ich will jetzt nicht zu sehr
ins Detail gehen, aber so, da waren
immer super Ideen dabei, aber ich
weiß nicht, ich glaube, der hat mich nicht ernst genommen, weil ich wollte
dann schon Fragen stellen, wie
das so ist als Profifussballer, aber ich hatte jetzt
nicht so den richtigen Einfallswinkel.
Ich konnte jetzt nicht fragen, wie, ah, wie ist
das in der Tabelle, so, ich habe ja keine Ahnung von Fußball. Also ich glaube, ich habe die falschen Fragen gestellt. Ich habe zum Beispiel gefragt, kann man zum Training seinen eigenen Ball mitnehmen? Oder nicht? Und er meinte, nee, wir haben da im Stadion Bälle. Ich wusste nicht, ob jeder seine eigene Frage hat. Das hat sich unter den Nägeln gebrannt, diese Frage. Ich wusste nicht, ob jeder seinen eigenen Ball hat. Aber ich habe mir immer so vorgestellt, morgens in der Trambahn sind alle Berufsgruppen zusammen und dann steigen die aus. Der Fussballer hat so einen Ball in der Hand. Der eine hat so einen Koffer, der andere hat so einen Fleischer. Aber der Anwalt nimmt ja auch nicht seinen Rechner mit. Ja doch. Ja, so. Und dann dachte ich, der Fussballer hat seinen Ball. Und dann sagt er so, ich muss nochmal aussteigen, ich habe meinen Ball vergessen. Das ist halt sein Sportarbeitsgerät. Und dann bringt er den Ball mit. Aber der meinte, nee, die haben da Bälle vor Ort, also muss das nicht mitbringen. Aber ich dachte, weißt du. Und dann sind die ja gesponsert von einer Ausrüstungsmarke, so Adidas oder Umbro oder so oder Hummel. Da frage ich mich, können die privat andere Sachen tragen, weil wenn die mal fotografiert werden und die tragen zum Beispiel Adidas Schuhe. Guck mal, das ist eine gute Frage. Das ist eine super gute Frage für jemanden, der im Sport ist. Ich habe die Frage gestellt, wenn man zu weit hinten liegt, kann man aufgeben. Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Wenn man bei Minute Minute siebzig zehn null hinten liegt, kann man sagen, wir geben auf. Lass uns die Zeit, genau, weil wir laufen hier gerade noch, das Energie, wenn nächste Woche wieder ein Spiel, lass doch lieber Regeneration. Ja, also ich dachte mir, es gibt so ein System, wenn sechs von elf Spielern die Hand heben und sagen, ich will nicht mehr, dann gibt die Mannschaft auf, aber meint dann, nee.
Das finde ich immer eine gute Frage, ehrlich gesagt.
Also ich schaue das als Laie
und denke mir, gut, 10-0, aber
müssen die denn jetzt noch weitermachen?
Die Bayern ja auch 8-0 gewonnen, die Bayern.
Ja. Haben 8-0 gewonnen.
Ja. Und da habe ich mich auch gefragt, kann man da nicht
irgendwann sagen, also wenn die jetzt, keine Ahnung,
wenn 6-0 steht in der 80. Minute,
lasst uns doch die 10 Minuten sparen. Ja. Aber dann sagen die Sponsoren, nee, nee, wir haben ja dafür bezahlt, Bandenwerbung. Verstehe, da geht es gar nicht wirklich um Sport und so, aber ist auch verrückt, weil dann war ich auch in so einem Stadion, ich war noch nie in einem Fussballstadion und da wurde aber gerade nicht gespielt, das war einfach so Feierabend, Stadion hatte Feierabend und da waren so ganz viele Leuchtstrahler so ganz niedrig auf dem Rasen, anscheinend um den Rasen irgendwie wieder aufzupeppen nach oder vor einem Spiel. Oder bei einem Konzert vorher oder sowas. Nee, wirklich, die Lampen waren direkt auf dem Rasen, also so ein Meter Abstand oder so. Aber komplett, die ganze Fläche? Komplett so ein Drittel vielleicht, aber da waren so grosse Gestelle und für mich, also das ist ja manchmal so, dass man mit Licht irgendwie Kleber härten kann oder pflanzen, dass die besser wachsen, weil der Rasen, der muss ja immer perfekt sein. Oder war das ein Konzert? Nein, da war gar nichts los. Entweder es war ein extrem schlecht besuchtes Konzert, wo selbst der Künstler nicht aufgetaucht hat. Dass die so die Traversen runterfahren, um die abzubauen. Nee, ich glaube, also ich habe das gesehen und mein Gärtnerkopf dachte, ah, die beleuchten den Rasen, damit der schneller regeneriert. Und ich fand das so beeindruckend, weil man darf auch auf gar keinen Fall auf den Rasen. Wenn du in so einem Stadion bist, du darfst da überall rumlaufen und so, da war so ein Event und so, aber auf gar keinen Fall auf den Rasen. Konzert? Nein, es war kein Konzert, Stefan. Und ich finde es so beeindruckend, weil normalerweise ist Gras die unbeeindruckendste Pflanze, die ist immer im Weg, wenn du sagst so default, wenn da irgendwas wächst, Gras. Aber in dem Stadion ist es die wertvollste, empfindlichste Pflanze, gar keinen Fall auf Gras, bitte nicht Gras, aber ausserhalb des Stadions sinkt der Kurs rapide und Gras ist, äh, mäht es, weg da, reißt es aus, auf Golfplätzen steigt der Kurs wieder stark, aber das fand ich so beeindruckend, dass die unwichtigste Pflanze in einem Fussballstadion extrem wichtig wird. Also die haben da nicht mal irgendwie Lotusblumen, so besondere Sachen, sondern die haben Gras, so das niederste, gängigste Pflanzengras. Aber so ein geiles Gras, was so richtig schön gleichmässig dicht ist. Ich finde da so eine Faszination für Gras. Ja, so Rasen. Ja, so Rasen, so ein geiler, ein guter Rasen. Da ist auch nichts anderes drin, da ist nicht mal so ein Löwenzahn. Ja, aber auch so auf Golfplätzen so ein ganz feiner Rasen, wo du nicht, du siehst ja wirklich, obwohl wenn du drauf guckst, genau drauf guckst, 90 Grad, guckst du runter, müsstest du ja eigentlich Erde sehen, weil da sind ja kleine Pinne, die nach oben gehen, aber es ist komplett grün, weil es so dicht wächst. Wie so eine kurze Stoppelfrisur. Das schon krass aber man darf man darf keine löcher graben oder so also man darf nicht es ist so geil so dicht aber auch glaube ich gar nicht gut für die umwelt so monokultur schritt da hat er keinen platz mehr für anderen zeug guck mal das wäre auch eine gute frage gewesen habe ich auch nicht gestellt ich hatte nur die falschenchen Fragen. Ist er denn noch nervös, wenn er spielt? Ist er nervös vor so vielen Leuten? Weiß ich nicht. Ich habe nur gefragt, wie lang vorm Spiel muss man im Stadion sein? Weil das ist so, wenn das Spiel, ich weiß auch nicht wann so ein Spiel ist, 18 Uhr, keine Ahnung. Und dann dachte ich mir so, muss man da schon um 12 Uhr morgens im Stadion sein? Wie wir immer, bei so Auftritten. Genau, so wie Auftritten, wann muss man da sein? Wann ist Beyonce? Was ist er vorm Fußballspiel? Das will ich gerne wissen. Bei mir kommt beim Sport immer alles hoch. Ich kann davor nicht essen. Ach so. Ist er vorm Spiel so ein ... Fuck! Hat er meine Chance und ich hab's nicht gestellt. Er hat's nicht genutzt. Aber er meinte, 90 Minuten vorm Anpfiff ist man im Stadion, man verbringt aber schon den Tag mit der Mannschaft. Ich habe mal nämlich einen Kochkurs gehabt, bei dem ehemaligen Koch vom FC Köln. Den ehemaligen. Ich habe mal einen Kochkurs. Der rausgeschmissen, rausgewechselt, warum war er eh? Selbstständig gemacht. Selbstständig gemacht. Ja genau, Restaurant einfach, keine Ahnung. Der hat jedenfalls so einen Kochkurs gegeben, habe ich verschenkt, war richtig cool. Wir haben Fisch gekocht und sowas. hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht und denen habe ich sehr viele Fragen gestellt. Und er hat viel erzählt von seinem Beruf als Mannschaftskoch. Was natürlich sehr spannend ist, die haben auch teilweise dann in der Champions League gespielt oder so, er war auch bei Leverkusen, die haben in der Champions League gespielt, Köln glaube ich nicht, lange nicht mehr. Und Leverkusen hat dann irgendwie so gegen Schachtor Donetsk gespielt in der Priege. Und da wollten die Spieler natürlich, die sollen das gleiche Essen bekommen, was sie zu Hause bekommen. Also reisen die Ärzte viel eher dahin, um sozusagen die Supermärkte zu scouten, die Märkte zu scouten. Die Köche, ja. Genau, die Köche reisen dahin, um zu gucken, was gibt es da alles. Ah ja. Also reisen viel früher dahin. Und dann kriegen die Spieler tatsächlich fast genau das gleiche Essen, was sie hier bekommen, damit die Mägen sich nicht umgewöhnen müssen und so. Die können auch keine Krankheiten riskieren. Aber wäre es dann nicht einfacher, irgendwie McDonalds zu essen, weil das überall gleich ist? Tatsächlich ja, wahrscheinlich schon. Weil dann, wenn du immer vorm Spiel einen Big Mac isst, den kriegst du in jeder Stadt der Welt wahrscheinlich. Und was sie machen ist, das ist besonders krass, die Spieler werden konditioniert, die haben dann normale Spieleinheiten, Trainingseinheiten, wo sie normal trainieren, und dann gibt es so Einheiten, wo sie besonders viel Gas geben müssen, so maximale Ausdauertrainien, so maximal Belastungseinheiten. Davor kriegen sie immer einen Milchreis, so zwei Stunden vor so einer Maximaleinheit kriegen sie ein Milchreis. Und dann kriegen die Spieler quasi vor den Spielen, wo der Körper direkt so ans Maximum gehen soll, kriegen sie auch ein Milchreis. Und der Körper erinnert sich, er hat die letzten hundert Male immer Milchreis bekommen, danach volles Tempo gegeben und sozusagen der Milchreis war dann so der Trigger für den Körper, um sich zu erinnern, ah, jetzt Maximalbelastung zu gehen. Und du kannst natürlich auch, wenn du halt plötzlich Champions League-Spiel hast, die sind um 21 Uhr abends, fangen die erst an, Bundesligaspiele 15.30. Die Mägen sollen sich nicht, dein Körper soll denken, ah, jetzt ist Spieltag und soll sich nicht mit diesen Uhrzeiten befassen. Also kriegst du die gleichen Mahlzeiten, die gleichen Stunden vorher und der Körper weist dann. Also es war super krass, wie sozusagen dann so Wissenschaft, Psychologie mit dem Kochen so einhergehen. Aber wenn sie verlieren, kriegen sie ein Eis. Ja, kriegen sie einen Lolli. Ich weiß nicht, wie man das dann macht, ob man dann, kann ich noch ein Nogger haben. Nö. Aber ich war nicht so gut. Nee, war nicht so gut, ne? Aber ich finde es gut, dass du sagst ehemaliger Köln-Koch, weil oft ist es ja so, wenn die Mannschaft schlecht spielt, musst du als Trainer Konsequenzen ziehen. Das ist klar. Aber du willst jetzt vielleicht keinen Spieler rausschmeissen? So,
die letzten Monate haben wir nicht gut
gespielt und
ich habe es angekündigt
und wir müssen jetzt durchgreifen, also wir ziehen es Konsequenzen.
Ich habe mich mit dem
Trainerteam beschlossen, als Geschäftsführer vom
FC Köln.
Ist uns die Entscheidung nicht leicht gefallen, aber
Scheisse, Mann, ich weiss,
die Abwehr war so löchrig, ich werde fliegen. Nee, wir schmeissen dich raus, Gregor, den Koch. Mich? Moi? Moi? Le Chef? Le Chef fliegt. Le Chef fliegt. Le ... Aber ... Du bist raus. Excusez-moi, ich habe nicht den Torla reingelassen. Ich habe immer gekocht, die guten Milchreis. Immer für die Jungs. Ja, aber die Leute waren träge, die Leute waren träge, du hast irgendwie die Selbstverdächtigung. Ja, aber das liegt dann doch nicht an meiner Kisch. Nein, wir müssen die Entscheidung treffen. Wir müssen die Entscheidung treffen. Ich soll jetzt hier abgesägt werden für ihren Misserfolg? Nächste zwei Wochen später, es läuft immer noch sehr, sehr schlecht. Ja, deswegen haben wir jetzt Konsequenzen gezogen, wir schmeissen dich raus, Gärtner, der Gärtner ist raus.
Ich?
Ja, du bist raus. Der Rasen war vielleicht nicht gut oder keine Ahnung, also du bist jetzt raus.
Gärtner ist raus, also wir müssen jetzt dann doch wirklich durchgreifen und Rudi der Hausmeister, du musst gehen.
M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M-M- dir der Hausmeister, du musst gehen. Michserauswerfen!
Michserauswerfen, keine gute Idee.
Ja, es gab eh Probleme
mit diesem Gangenaustausch
System, das
glaube ich hat nicht gut funktioniert, das sind unterschiedliche Kulturen,
die hier, danke
für deine Dienste, aber
ja, klar, du musst durchgreifen manchmal, manchmal braucht man Bauernopfer, auf jeden Fall. Bauernopfer, ja, eine Schachmetapher. Ach so, ich dachte jetzt eine klassische Mittelalter-Königsmetapher. Ach so, es ist nämlich ein Mittelalter-König, ja, es ist das Gleiche, Schach ist ja auch das Spiel der Könige, wo man sich dann am Ende fragen muss ja was muss man sich was muss sich am ende fragen was muss man sich am ende fragen ob es nicht der gleiche bauer gemeint ist ja ja genau nee genau das war meine idee geogäste ins museum stellen um herauszufinden wer kennt sich auch sozusagen nicht nur konkret wer merkt sich diese pinne die fahrgab farblinienbegrenzung oder sowas, wo die merken, ah okay, das muss der Markt sein. Ja, da gibt es ja viele Tricks. Lame! Lameo! Sagt mir, ah, das ist Köln anhand von so einem schlechten Mittelalter-Gemälde. Ist natürlich auch interessant dann zu sehen, wie stark sich Städte verändert haben oder nicht, oder ob ein moderner Geogester sagen kann, das ist doch Ulm. Eben. Das ist doch Ulm, das sehe ich doch auf den ersten Blick, weil man dann weißiss, ah doch historisch die Strukturen sind geblieben, die Stadt, die Mauer und so. Warum ist die Stadtmauer immer mitten in der Stadt? Weil die Städte damals so klein waren. Wirklich waren die damals auch schon so klein? Windzig klein. Und dann sagt man, ja gut, und was war danach, einfach ein Feld war dann da oder was? Oder hat man gesagt, nee, nur die Hälfte der Stadt ist innerhalb der Mauern und die anderen müssen dann da rein oder was? Genau. Quatsch. Man muss denn da eine grössere Mauer bauen, ne? Hast du dann so diese Ringe? Ja, die zweite, eine grössere Burg nebenan. Diese Ringstundbauer. Und dann ziehen alle nebenan in die grössere Burg. Sehr viel einfacher. Es ist viel einfacher, wenn wir einfach eine grössere Burg nebendran bauen und wir da hingehen. Ja, ja. Ja, ja. Ja, ist natürlich auch eine Zweiklassengesellschaft, innerhalb, inneren Kreis, ausser Kreis. Die einen werden, die einen können bleiben.
Ich war in Köln jetzt zum ersten Mal in dem Duftmuseum, also Farina ist nämlich, also Köln ist ja bekannt als die Stadt, wo das Parfum erfunden wurde, das Eau de Colonne.
Ja.
Und da früher haben wir die Städte bestialisch gestunken so doll dass es wirklich eine b-burg gab und die stadt ist halt komplett umgezogen in diese zweite burg häufig weil es so sehr gestunken hat die sind halt wirklich die erste sich ausgestunken hat quasi und dann irgendwann wieder erträglich und den mann einfach verlassen und dann ist man eine, weil es dann nicht so gestunken hat. Das ist wirklich passiert. Und in Köln wurde sozusagen das Heilmittel dagegen erfunden, Parfum. Und jetzt denkt man natürlich, es ist immer 4711, weil die sich irgendwie marketingtechnisch durchgesetzt haben, aber es war in Wirklichkeit Farina. Es war ein Italiener, der hat hier gewohnt, mochte Köln, hat sich niedergelassen und hat hier das Parfum empfunden, weil er konnte, das war sein Skill, Alkohol so klar destillieren, dass es nicht mehr nach Alkohol gerochen hat, sondern sehr geruchsfrei war. Du brauchst ja Alkohol als Geruchsträger. Er konnte das besonders gut, besonders rein, deswegen war er ein guter Parfumeur. und Und er hat das gemacht. Und das gibt es immer noch unverändert, das erste Parfüm der Welt. Unverändert kann man das da probieren. Und es riecht wirklich gut. Und es ist das gleiche Parfüm, was Napoleon, der war Fan davon, der hatte das. Napoleon, du kannst quasi sein Geruch riechen. Alexander von Humboldt hatte das auch. Und wonach riecht das? Ja, so ein bisschen zitronig. Aber ein guter Geruch. Ein bisschen zitronig, ein guter Geruch eigentlich. Ist halt heute ein bisschen in Verruf geraten, dadurch, dass viele Putzmittel halt nach Zitrone riechen. Hast du, glaube ich, eher so diesen Klostein viel. Aber es riecht wirklich, du hast es richtig in der Klosche, es riecht wirklich immer noch gut, also es ist wirklich ein sehr, sehr guter Geruch. Es war unfassbar teuer, es war wirklich ein Vermögen, eine so eine Ampulle. Und dann haben die sich das draufgeballert, weil es hat alles nach Schweiss gestunken und die hatten noch nicht so viele Klamotten, dann hatten die immer diese krassen Kleider, dann immer dieses Schminke im Gesicht, es hat gestunken und dann kam jemand um die Ecke und hat das zum ersten Mal wahrscheinlich alle so, what? Moment, aber das heißt, man parfümiert sich selbst ein, damit man den Geruch von anderen nicht riecht. Naja, naja, ich glaube, um selber gut zu riechen. Um selber gut zu riechen, um als Statussymbol zu sagen, ich bin der Einzige, der nicht stinkt. Weil es gibt ja auch diese Möglichkeiten, sich selber so unter die Nase zu reiben, damit du das nicht mehr riechst. Ja, ja, bestimmt auch. Vor allem, wenn du selber ein Parfüm drauf machst, riechst du es ja auch selber, also wahrscheinlich jetzt auch hilft es auch in der Richtung. Ich glaube, ab einer gewissen Evolutionsstufe ist Geruch hinderlich. Also ist Geruch heute noch nötig? Gut zu riechen, schlecht zu riechen? Ja, oder überhaupt zu riechen. Weg damit! Weg damit, die Gehirnareale, die alle mit Geruch irgendwie jetzt ... Ich liebe Geruch, nur Essen ist nur Geruch. Ja, okay, ja, Essen, das ist ein Thema, ja, aber das kriegen wir auch anders hin, das kriegen wir umgepolt. Schmecken, oder was? Ja, schmecken ist okay, aber Riechen ist nicht Riechen. Schmecken ist Riechen. Schmecken ist nicht Riechen. Schmecken und Riechen sind zwei Teile derselben medaille aber es ist das gleiche so es bedingt sich dadurch ist das gleiche die nase ist überflüssig weil die nase du atmest durch die nase nur durch den mund ich habe es einen pickel auf der nase bekommen riesen pickel auf der nase direkt vorne dran ja da habe ich auch gedacht nase ist unnötig nase ist absolut unnötig nase ist schwer zu zeichnenicht ständig, unnötige Löcher, warum zwei, riechen muss nicht sein, nervt eher, weg mit der Nase. Ja, Punkt, weil seitdem du anfängst zu zeichnen, argumentierst du irgendwie immer in diese Richtung, also du hast schon gesagt, ich soll mir die Hand abschneiden. Ja, die Hände, warum haben wir so viele Finger? Die meisten Sachen kannst du mit einem Finger locker machen. Nein, doch klar, natürlich, ich greife Dinge und so. natürlich. Du kannst mit zwei Händen dann greifen. Das ist doch kein Problem. Ja, naja, gut, okay, die Geste will ich auch nicht mehr sehen, ehrlich gesagt. Den Mittelfinger. Sorry, da würde ich mich für entschuldigen. Ja, okay, gut, ja, mach doch deine Entschuldigungsgeste. Ach, das ist keine Geste. Ich meine nur, du argumentierst komischer, dem du zeichnest. Ich finde einfach, die Nase ist unnötig, die Henne sind unnötig. Lern doch einfach eine Hand zu zeichnen. Und warum stehen wir eigentlich alle immer so hintereinander? Können wir nicht alle auf der gleichen Ebene nebeneinander stehen? Ich meine, das ist doch unnötig. Dann stehen wir alle Schulter an Schultern nebeneinander. Hey, du kannst doch abstrakt malen einfach. Ciao. Wer war das gerade? Weiß nicht. Moment mal, das war Mann mit einem Schuh auf als Kopf? Der hatte einen Schuh als Kopf. Der hatte einen Schuh aus Kopf und war ein Strichmännchen. Diese abstrakten Künstler? Du kannst aber abstrakt malen. Wenn dir die Realität nicht so gefällt, wie sie ist, wende Phantasie an. Finde ich aber jetzt gemein, dass du abstrakte Künstler darstellst, als die, die nicht richtig gut zeigen können. Doch, doch, die können gut zeigen, das soll bestimmt gut sein. Finde ich albern, finde ich Quatsch, finde ich eine blöde, blöde, blöde Sichtweise auf die Kunstwelt, gefällt mir gar nicht. Ja, ja, ist schon recht. Gefällt mir nicht, also finde ich blöde, finde ich richtig blöde. Wir waren in den grossen Museen der Welt und ich glaube, da hast du was anderes gelernt. Ich glaube, das brauchst du gar nicht. Du hast schon recht und wir sind da eigentlich weiter in dem Diskurs. Abstrakte Kunst finde ich jetzt irgendwie, weiss nicht, finde ich nicht okay. Ja, sorry, findest du doof. Finde ich nicht okay. Da muss ich mich auch mal schützen für meine Kollegin. Apropos Zeichnen können Kunst, Grafiker, Grafikerin sein. Vielen, vielen Dank an euch, denn wir hatten den grossen Community Drop angekündigt und uns leben gerufen. Wir haben euch gefragt, könnt ihr uns unterstützen mit Motiven? Macht mit unserem UFO, was auch immer ihr wollt. und wir haben sechs fantastische Künstler und Künstlerinnen von euch gefunden und ausgewählt. Wir haben tolle Motive, die es jetzt auf ausgewählten Produkten gibt. Shirts, Half-Zip, Sweaters, Sweaters, Hoodies und Shirts. Ich freue mich auch selber, sie tragen zu dürfen, allerdings nur noch bis Ende des Jahres bestellbar. Ab dann werden sie erst produziert, ab dann werden erst gedruckt, gestampft, gerührt und gepresst, davor passiert gar nichts. Es ist ein Limited Drop, passt ein bisschen auf. Wir wollen nicht die Frage lesen, oh nein, ich hab's verpasst, kann man das nochmal bestellen? Nein, Antwort lautet nein. Limited Drop ist Ende des Jahres und erst danach werden sie verschickt und ich freue mich sehr darauf und falls ihr jetzt denkt, ah, fantastisch, ich bin-Club-Mitglied, da kriege ich ja auf alles 10% im Shop. Nein. Doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch, alles kein Problem. Nein, darauf nicht. Wir haben auch generell wahnsinnig viel Spaß im Club, schaut da mal vorbei, da kriegt ihr immer die werbefreie Folge, einen Tag früher und als Videopodcast und 10% Rabatt, falls ihr Bock habt. Also schaut mal vorbei, bis Ende des Jahres könnt ihr noch bestellen und danach nie, nie wieder. Und das meinen wir ernst, nicht so wie McDonalds, die jetzt den McRib wieder zurückbringen. Ich habe damals mehr bezahlt, weil ich dachte, der ist limitiert. Ja, ich weiß noch, ich habe einmal einen McRib bekommen ohne Soße. Und war das ein guter? Das war nicht gut, aber ich war damals noch nicht so charakterstark. Warst du ein Sau? Ja, ich war hungrig und habe gegessen, was da war. Aber es war auf jeden Fall eine enttäuschende Möglichkeit. Ich habe trotzdem mal bei meiner MacRib-Liebe festgehalten. Passt ein bisschen auf, wir haben andere Schnitte. Klar, warum einfach machen?
Nee, genau,
wir sind ein bisschen mit der Zeit gegangen.
Wer nicht mit der Zeit geht, muss mit der Zeit gehen.
Und deswegen sind wir mit der Zeit gegangen.
Warum schreiben wir das nicht auf ein T-Shirt?
Weil es ein Stromwerk-Zitat ist.
Jedenfalls gibt es ein bisschen oversized Sachen,
weil das trägt man gerade so.
Ich liebe das, Leute tragen das gerade. Also schaut, das sind fantastisch coole neue Schnitte, die glaube ich, da seid ihr die schicksten auf der Strasse. Schaut mal vorbei, podcast-ufe.fail, unser Merchshop, da könnt ihr alles euch angucken und dann entscheiden, ob ihr da Bock drauf habt. Vielen Dank. Und gebt uns eure Daten. Gebt uns all eure Daten. Ja. Wir lieben Daten. Was machen wir mit den Daten? Ich weiss nicht, aber ich stelle mir so vor, dass wenn man bei uns bestellt, man alle Daten hinterlassen muss. Dachte ich gerade. Auch viel zu viele Daten. Also Sternzeichen, Geburtsort. Aber Sternzeichen brauchen wir streng genommen nicht, wenn wir das Geburtsdatum haben. Oh, ich habe mir neulich meine Feng Shui-Glückszahl ausgerechnet, sechs ist die sechs, und mein Bett müsste in Richtung Nordwesten stehen. Steht es nicht. Und seitdem schlafe ich schlecht. Ah, das ist das Geheimnis von Feng Shui. Genau das Geheimnis von Feng Shui, seitdem ich weiss, dass es falsch rumsteht, seitdem schlafe ich schlecht. Aber wie viele Glückszahlen gibt es? Eins bis neun. Eins bis neun, okay. Ich dachte schon, meine Zahl ist 16.438. Und ich habe die sechs. Ich habe nie, du hast die sechs. Ich weiß nicht, ob es besser ist. Aber okay, finde ich gut. Hat das nicht auch so Regeln, dass man irgendwie, dass ein Frosch irgendwie nach draußen zeigen muss, damit man Glück und Geld bekommt oder irgendwie sowas? Es gibt ja nicht auch so Frosch-Symboliken, aber die Frage ist halt, wo kriegst du einen toten Frosch irgendwie nach draußen zeigen muss, damit man Glück und Geld bekommt oder irgendwie sowas.
Gibt es ja nicht auch so Frosch-Symboliken, aber die Frage ist halt, wo kriegst du einen toten Frosch her?
Wo kriege ich jetzt einen toten Frosch her?
Ich bin sehr schnell erschöpft gewesen bei diesem ganzen Fingerschuikram.
Alles klar, gut, dann wünsche ich mir eigentlich eine schöne Woche.
Komm, du musst noch kurz deine Sachen eingeben.
Mach ganz schnell, das geht ganz schnell.
Ah, das ist die Kurzahl.
Die heissen immer Rechner.
Rechne deine Zahl aus, rechne deine Glückszahl aus.
Am Ende musst du dein Geburtsdatum eingeben, deine Grösse, dein Gewicht und dann bist du durch mit der ganzen Nummer.
Ich finde das immer so ein bisschen albern.
Moment, du musst wirklich nur dein Geschlecht und dein Geburts.
Genau.
Geschlecht, Geburtsjahr, Geburtsdatum und dann kannst du auf den Button klicken, ausrechnen, damit du mit einer schwierigen Formel dann errechnen, was du hast. Ich habe aus Versehen als Geburtsjahr 19.000 geschrieben. Okay. Ja und jetzt? also florentin, deine Kurzahl ist die neun. Ich bin genau das Gegenteil von dir. Du bist die sechs und ich bin auf dem Kopf. Und du bist bislang der Erste mit einer klaren Richtung. Also nicht so, weil ich habe Nordwest ist meine Richtung. Deine Richtung ist Süden. Fucking Süden. Süden. Wie die Enten. Süden. Wie die Enten. Süden. Einfach direkt nach Süden. Aber die Neun ist deine Glückszahl. Die Neun ist meine Glückszahl, alles klar. Sag mal drei Dinge, die einfallen in deinem Leben mit Neun. Die Neun, da würde ich mich freuen. Da habe ich kein Bräunen. Aber hat die Neun nur was mit dir gemacht? Die Neun hat was mit mir gemacht. Neun Zwerge, neun Königreiche, neun Klingelt gerade nicht. Ich glaube, mein Glücksmoment ist noch in der Zukunft. Irgendwann, wenn ich die neun sehen werde, werde ich vielleicht sagen, heute ist mein Glückstag. So oder so, die Folge 389 ist die nächste Folge. Also, weil ihr die nächste Folge sehen wollt und euch sagt,
vielleicht ist das die Glücksfolge, dann seid nächste
Woche wieder mit dabei. Bis dahin wünschen wir
euch eine ganz schöne Woche. It's a worse bird production.